(upbeat music)
(applause)
- Good morning.
So let's start with this.
How many people in this
room by show of hands
have no idea who I am,
raise your hand, that hurts.
(laughing)
I thought that would be the case.
First of all, I've really been enjoying.
I'm a business man, I'm an entrepreneur.
Obviously I make content, I write books.
But I'm extremely proud
that for the last 20 years
from literally the day that
I left college till this
moment right now, I've
been operating a business.
And spending the last week or
two looking at this industry
and the dynamics was
interesting to me 'cause I think
context really matters and
I think one of the things
that affords me the ability
to continue to speak at
conferences, which I enjoy so
much so thank you for having
me is that I don't have a can speech.
I have things I believe in
but I think context matters.
And I was exciting digging
into this world because one,
as I was digging I realized a
couple of my friends were in
it so I was able to get under
the hood a little bit more
and two, this is a perfect cliche example
of an industry and I know
there's multiple parties
and chain in this room and
I'll try to address both
or all three where I have
empathy to why the majority
of people don't think or
fully understand what the
impact of a Facebook or
an Instagram or a Snapchat
mean to them in a business world.
And as you can imagine for
me, that's super exciting
'cause that means literally
all I have to do is over
the course of the next hour
articulate in business terms
and create the emotion to
the action of literally
just one or two individuals in this
entire conference to
actually make an impact.
I think what's most fascinating
for me is industries,
look if you sell sneakers
to 20 year olds, I think
it makes sense that
Instagram or Facebook matter.
When you're in a b to b
dynamic and trying to win big
accounts or trying to
become a supplier to a big
organization, it becomes less obvious.
However it's funny I
get to see Mickey Cloud
here who runs our Chattanooga office.
When I looked at him, I'm
thinking back to the greatest
successes at Vayner
Media the last six years
and when I think about our
biggest financial impact
it has been far more
than General Electrics
of the SAPs and the B to b
business than it has been
the Budweiser's or the Pepsi's
because as a lot of you
know when you play b to b and
I'm in the b to b business
now, all it takes is one
account for it to start
getting really interesting
and so because so many of
you don't know who I am
I'm gonna give you a little
bit of my origin story because
it's gonna give you a lot
of ammo to actually make the
leap that I hope that you consider.
I was born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union.
I came to the US when I was three.
We lived a very humble
beginning as you can imagine.
The economy wasn't super great.
We didn't speak English.
We have 100 bucks, I
lived with seven family
members in a studio apartment in Queens.
So it was super humble
and obviously my parents
are very much my heroes one because my mom
is the greatest parent of all time.
And two because my dad works his face off
and even though I slept
under the same roof literally
every day of my life with
my dad in the first 14 years
of my life, I literally
never saw him because
he left at seven am or six
am and he came home at 10 pm.
And he worked seven days a week.
How many people here are
immigrants or children
of immigrants, raise your hands, awesome.
So this group that just raised you hands,
they know that immigrants
in America have absolutely
figured out one of the core
secrets which is work your
face off and don't buy dumb shit.
And so that's what my family
did for seven or eight years.
My dad wasn't making that
much money but a funny thing
happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest
possible price and save,
save, save and very quickly,
only six years after coming
to America with 100 bucks,
my dad was able to buy a small
liquor store in New Jersey.
We moved to New Jersey, that
is where my entrepreneurial
career began, when I was six I had a five
lemonade stand franchise.
I manipulated my friends
into standing behind
the lemonade all day and
that is when I became
obsessed with attention and
this is really interesting.
As you can see up here,
I day trade attention,
culture and build businesses.
At six years old, I would
spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the
streets of New Jersey
sitting down on the curb
watching cars drive by
so that I could figure
out which tree or post
was better for me to put
a sign that said Lemonade,
a quarter, that is DNA,
that's like somebody singing.
That's like somebody throwing a pitch.
That is just pure DNA, I
didn't read a Seth Godin
book or go to Harvard
Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset.
The one thing that
combines every person here
from the camera man back
there who are producing
to the industry that is in
this room from me to Mickey
to anybody else that sneaked
in, the one thing that
fundamentally connects all
of us is before you tell
me how great your product and service is,
you need my attention so that I listen.
I am obsessed with attention.
I am obsessed with this device
because it has the attention.
I am unemotional if it's ruining the kids
and they don't know how to
engage or they you were sad
that people go out to dinner
and don't talk to each other.
Technology does not care
about your feelings.
And so I as a human may
have some opinions about
parenthood and society
and privacy as a human.
But as a business man, I am
unemotional and not romantic.
All I do is follow where the
attention is and I figure
out how to story tell in there
to create the action that
I desire whether that is
to sell a pair of sneakers
or a book or my agency or
whether that's to raise money
for the Crohn's and
Colitis Foundation 'cause
my brother has it or get
my friend elected mayor.
It is completely arbitrary
but there is one religion.
Where is the attention of
our consumer and I think the
thing, the delta, the most
important and exciting thing
for me in this room today is
yes there is some attention,
of course, at a conference,
if you set up a booth.
And yes there is attention
if you spam everybody
24 hours a day on LinkedIn
or cold call or decide
to buy a full page ad in the
business to business magazine
that four people open, yes,
there is some attention.
But in 2018 if you do not
realize that that is overpriced
attention, then you are vulnerable
for the growth of your business.
I spend all my time
thinking about overpriced
and underpriced attention and
what's happening in culture.
I navigated from my lemonade
stand to baseball cards
because I'm 42 and in
1987, eight, nine, 1990,
baseball cards was the culture.
Every kid was buying them
and that was my life.
I was really unusual eastern
European immigrant that
came during that time,
every one of my friends,
every one of my parent's
friend's kids were straight a
students 'cause education was the way out.
If you go to Instagram literally right now
and look at my account
Garyvee two posts ago,
I posted my high school report card 'cause
nobody believes me but I was
a straight d and f student.
Somewhere around fourth
grade I realized that Saturn
was not going to impact my life
and I didn't care about it.
And so self awareness is a son of a bitch.
And honestly besides health
for everybody in this room,
I wish you self awareness
'cause once you understand
who you are, you can do a lot of damage.
All of us suck at a lot of stuff.
All of us are good at a lot of stuff.
The game is to figure that out.
I, through good parenting,
through circumstance,
through who knows really
what got very self aware
very early in my life and
listen, at 13, listen,
it was tough for my friend's
parents to say I was a loser
'cause I got d's and f's.
It wasn't fun for my
teachers to say that I wasn't
gonna amount to anything.
Here was my biggest problem.
I was 13 years old, I was
making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards, I had
$47,000 in cash under my bed
and I wasn't selling weed,
I thought I was amazing.
(laughing)
(applause)
I turned 14 and then
my dad ruined my life.
I'm the oldest son, first
generation, born in the old
country, that means one
thing, 14th birthday,
all weekends and summer
vacations are eliminated.
I got work in the liquor
store, 12 hours a day,
bagging ice, two bucks
an hour, I go from making
$3,000 a weekend, being a
king, to making $24 a weekend.
My dad was born in the Soviet
Union which means that he
hates his employees.
(laughing)
Which meant the four foot 11
me going into that environment
was really bad for me
'cause they hated him back.
And so those two years
literally every weekend,
every summer vacation, my
leisure, my childhood ended in
eighth grade, I had my friends
but I just never saw them
outside of school so I
was old school, right?
I was much more a merchant's
son from the 50s, 40s and 60s.
Just happened to be growing
up in the 80s and 90s.
And so for two years I
was stuck in a basement.
I call those the dark years
and then finally my junior
year of high school when
I turned 17 I was allowed
to come upstairs and then my
life really took a big change.
I realized that people collected wine.
And because I was so into
collecting baseball cards
and those things, that became
the passion connector for me
and basically I went from
reading the Beckett Baseball
Card Guide in school 24
hours a day to reading
the Wine Spectator in
school 24 hours a day.
And 17, 18, I decided, first
of all it was fun to get
to know my dad even though
he was rough, it was fun.
And two, it was the family business,
decided I was gonna go
into it and in 1993, 1994,
I thought I would open up,
I used to have it in my mind
as I'll open up 1800 of these.
I will build the Toys 'R Us of wine.
I will sell the franchise one
day, buy the New York Jets,
win some Super Bowls, call it a day.
So that was basically the
plan at 17 and basically
the Jets part is still in play.
Everything else has evolved.
So I was a terrible student.
I thought I wasn't gonna go to college.
Another thing some of the kids
of immigrants in here know
is that your parents don't
know stuff so my mom came to
me February of my senior
year, literally 90 days before
we graduate and says to me
so what are you doin' about
college and I laughed and I
said mom, what do you talking
about, we missed it,
I didn't take my SATs.
I didn't apply for school,
I have to go to work in the
business, I knew my mom would
be embarrassed if I went
to a community college so I
knew that was her Kryptonite
so I was super pumped, I
thought I figured it all out.
Some of you may have a Soviet mother.
She looked me dead in
the face and she said
you better figure it
out or I'm gonna punch
you in the face until you bleed.
So as fate would have it,
this is literally how I went
to college, I think this
will be interesting to you.
Literally the next day I
get a postcard in the mail,
in the mail a postcard, we
got mail, I went to go get
the mail, there's a post
card from Mount Ida College.
Literally I filled out
my name and my address.
I sent it in and that's
how I went to college.
So this is the college I
went to just so everybody's
grounded, I'm in my
dorm room Freshman year.
I'm playing Madden '94
dominating by the way and my
friend runs in and goes you
have to come and see this.
I finish off my game, I
go in and I see seven guys
standing around a computer, this is 1994.
I had been on a computer for
maybe 15 hours in my life
because I failed typing
class and computers
so I never did it, I had a
Word Processor that I was
supposed to use, I never did.
And I'm looking at this computer
and it was the first time I heard.
(mimicking connectivity signals)
That whole thing and
looking around there's not
that many youngsters,
how many people here do
not remember the world pre
internet, raise your hand,
you're that young, not
that you have a bad memory.
You're just under 30, raise
your hands, okay good, not many.
So for everybody else we
actually remember the world
pre internet which is crazy
if you think about it now.
But we lived it and so the
first time I saw the internet
I literally sat there for
four hours watching other
people go on it 'cause it was so crazy.
A couple of other things
that were so crazy for the
three youngsters, it was
$2.99 an hour from AOL
or a minute, I don't
remember, all I remember
was that it was like $8000 a month
and thought it was a good deal.
(laughing)
17 minutes after I was
on internet I found,
after waiting for four hours to go on it
at like two o'clock in the morning,
I found myself on an AOL bulletin board
where people sold baseball cards.
That was the moment
that I realized I wasn't
gonna open up 1800 liquor stores.
15 months later I launched
one of the first three
eCommerce wine businesses in America
called winelibrary.com, 18 months later
I took over my dad's business.
Here's where it starts to matter for you.
Because I believe in following
where the attention is,
not where you think the
attention is or how you became
successful in the past, I
was able to grow my dad's
business that was doing
three million dollars a year
on 10% gross profit so
300,000 before expenses.
My first year marketing budget
was $14,000 for the year.
In a five year window
from 1998 to 2003 on that
without raising capital,
without getting a credit line,
on that financial situation
I built my dad's business
from a three to a 60 million
dollar a year business.
I did it because of timing,
I did it because email
had launched and I thought
it was a good idea to email
you wine offers instead of
sending you postcards that
cost me a lot of money, I did
it because Google Ad Words
had come out and I thought
it was a good idea to buy
the word wine for five
cents a click before
anybody knew what it was.
My entire career, what
allows me to be here today,
what allows me to dream
and be audacious about
owning a professional
football team is very simple.
I chase underpriced
attention, I chase properly
priced attention and I completely
bunt overpriced attention.
It's simple, I know that
everybody in this room
does things for eight to
10 hours a day every day
of the week, the month,
the year on things that
no longer bring as much
value as it did six, nine,
14 years ago that helped
you get to this point.
I know that there's somebody
in this room that if they
started a b to b podcast, I
know that if somebody in this
room who had never thought
about producing content
or media if they started a
podcast which they don't even
have the beginnings of a
thought of how to do that right
now, but the good news is
you literally go to Google
and you type in how do I start a podcast.
I know that if somebody
here started a podcast
for this industry and put
out an episode every week
and interviewed a thought
leader in this industry
that even though only 700 to
1500 people would listen to it
because it's obviously
very niche in it's content
that it would be the
differentiator of growing their
business, that it would
lead to lead gen, that
there are people that they're
trying to chase to get the
account that in turn, a
year later would be chasing
them to be a guest on
the show which then would
inevitably lead to them
getting the business.
My friends, please understand
over the next period of
time as I talk to you
about some of these nuances
that I am not a technologist,
that had I not been in
business that I wouldn't
want to have necessarily
an Instagram or Snapchat
or LinkedIn account.
It doesn't come natural to me.
It's not necessarily what I want.
What I want is to sell stuff.
What I want is to run
a successful business.
What I want is to win and to
me if you sit in this room
and you do not realize
how extreme the internet
technology revolution actually
is you become vulnerable.
If you do not understand
that book stores just happen
to be first, that limo services
just happen to be next,
if you do not understand
that everybody in this room
is vulnerable to technology
advances and that you either
jump on a surf board and
ride this wave or you face
the idea of looking at
this wave coming at you
and dealing with the ramifications.
To me this is not about
necessarily when I paint that
analogy the idea that you're
gonna go out of business.
To me, my biggest fear is
people, actually, how many
people grew in the last
year, if your business has
grown in 2017 compared to
2016, raise your hands.
Raise 'em high, be proud, it's awesome.
Let's actually clap it up for
this room, that's awesome.
(applause)
One more time for me
because I want context.
Raise it high, how many
people grew from 16 to 17?
So I'll be honest with you,
that's my biggest concern.
When I see a room of 70 or
80% of the room growing,
that's usually the biggest
challenge for my passions
and ambitions, winning in
the micro is usually a tell
to complacency to change or
invest or break the patterns
that have gotten you there, I get it.
It doesn't feel natural
when it's working to
take a 360 or make a hard turn.
But that's exactly the
passion I come here today with
which is the following, I
believe that everybody in this
room is in the media business.
I genuinely believe that
everybody here needs to become
the b to b magazine of their
industry, that everybody
here needs to put out content
on Facebook and LinkedIn
especially on a daily basis.
I also believe that 99% of
you don't agree with me.
And I genuinely believe
that, I understand that.
I see it everyday, I get it but to me,
the b to b sector with
service providers is exactly
the place where the opportunity
lies, let me explain.
My career is growing rapidly
on one very basic thesis.
I give away all my content for free.
Everything that I know,
everything that's working for me
I put out on YouTube and
Facebook and LinkedIn
and my email every day for free.
There is no mastermind,
there's no island that I want
you to come to and pay me $50,000.
There's no $900 eBook, there's
no funnel, there's nothing.
There's my content, it comes out.
Once every two years, I put out a book.
It's like 13 bucks on
Amazon, we call it a day.
There's a couple things that
most people don't understand
about this thesis, number
one, 99% of people don't
do anything with the information.
Fundamentally the most fascinating
thing to me about humans
is it's more fun to
complain than do, right?
Or it's more fun to paint
the narrative in your mind
than do, a lot of you in
this room who fear monger
technology love what's going
on right now with Facebook.
You are thrilled that Mark
Zuckerberg is testifying
right now in front of Congress.
You know why, 'cause you're lazy.
You love it because you
don't wanna take the time
to spend 100 or 200 hours to
figure out how to sell stuff
and get clients through
Facebook because it's hard.
And so you've made a romantic
point of view because
your children or grandchildren
didn't talk to you
and are looking at the phone,
you've started the subtle
path to fear mongering
technology and I think that's
awesome because for me, on the other side,
I want you to continue to hate it.
Because Facebook is
simple, it's a marketplace.
Look, if you're trying to
reach the decision maker
at a retail organization,
that guy or gal is also
the same person that I wanna
reach to sell a bottle of wine
or a book to and that space
in his and her Facebook feed
is only one space so that
is supply and demand.
I used to buy that space
four years ago for a dollar
for every thousand
impressions, now it's seven.
The longer you think
this world doesn't exist
and you fear monger it, the
longer you don't put money in,
the longer I can extract all the value.
I've lived this game, I'm
not a hero 'cause I took it
from three to 50 million, 60
million, my dad's business.
I actually am a schmuck, I
should've spent more on Google.
I had it figured out, every
time you typed in Cabernet,
Merlot, Silver Oak, Camus, Napa, Bor deut,
I was showing up first
'cause nobody realized it
was good real estate and
it was only costing me
five or 10 cents a click and
I was making between seven
and $80 in profit for
something that was costing
me three dollars to get
you through the funnel
on the average of 60 people
coming and one converting.
I was stupid, I'm being serious with you.
I stand here and have passion
about LinkedIn and Facebook
marketing and b to b
environment today out of regret
for what I did from 2002
to 2005 because I should've
spent more, it was basic math
but I just didn't understand.
Because I was young in my
career and it just, I don't even
know how to explain it to you
when it's too good to be true,
it's too good to be true,
right, I'm an immigrant.
I was cynical, I just
didn't, plus I also thought
it was important to do direct
mail and local commercials
and magazine, I was doing
it all but in hindsight
it was the great mistake of my career.
The great mistake of my
career was not spending more
money on Google and I
promise you the great mistake
of your accelerated growth
for the 80% that just raised
their hand is not taking
advertising on LinkedIn
and Facebook seriously
because you don't think
your person is on it, I've heard every.
Guys, I've been doing this for 10 years.
I know what your excuse is gonna be.
I can't wait till the Q and
A, I'm gonna stand here.
But Gary, my target person
is a 63 year old man.
He's not on it, bullshit,
of course he's on it.
Who do you think is
spreading all the democratic
and republican propaganda on Facebook?
(laughing)
(applause)
Literally this is my life, guys.
I go to meetings every day
with the biggest CEOs of
the world, the Pepsi's and
the Chase's, big companies,
CMOs, CEOs, and literally
they scold me for the first
30 minutes that Facebook
is running our democracy
because they know I've been
an advocate of this for a
decade, literally, this has
now happened three times
in the last 100 days,
I go to have breakfast.
It's a one hour breakfast,
we're there to talk business
but for the first 20 to 40
minutes, it gets completely
side tracked because that
individual wants to scold me.
Gary, you don't understand,
Facebook and Twitter
is tearing down the American democracy.
And then we spend the
last 20 minutes and they
explain to me that Facebook
is not effective in
selling lipstick and I
sit there and I say do you
just realize that you
just told me this platform
is powerful enough to tear
down the most powerful
institution in society but
then literally on the other
side of you mouth, you told
me that it doesn't sell your
product and that TV is better, watch this.
Let's all agree, this audience
is not filled with 13 year
old teenage girls, right,
this is, we're old, right?
We're all old, right, watch this.
By show of hands, how many
people here now mainly
watch Netflix or Amazon Prime
or what is called an OTT,
HBO, mainly those
platforms, raise your hands.
Actually please stand
up, please, I mean it.
I apologize, I know
you're lazy but stand up.
I want people to see
this, do not sit down yet.
And honestly if you mainly
watch Netflix or Amazon Prime
or Hulu or YouTube, guys, I
just need everybody to look
around, I have clients
that are spending 80,
Babon, get up here, get up
here, I wanna make sure all,
this is my vlog, it will be
on YouTube shortly, just.
So Vlog real quick, these
are old people, right?
(laughing)
This is 30s and 40s and
50s and 60s and 70s.
Look around, literally,
Jesus, 87% of this audience
doesn't even have the chance
to consume a commercial.
And the 13% that are
sitting that watch network,
when a commercial goes on, they grab this.
80 billion dollars spent
on commercials in America
and nobody and I mean nobody is watching.
Cool, thank you, thank you.
It is true and what's scary
about that and here's my thing.
It is true and you know what else is true,
the 10s of billions of dollars
that are spent on banner
ads and digital nobody's
clicking and looking at either.
This is not an argument about new or old.
This is an argument about common sense.
And common sense and data
are very obvious on this.
Everybody here can sell a
lot more stuff if they take
the 100 hours to learn
how to do written words,
pictures and videos on
Facebook and LinkedIn
and it will fundamentally
change your business
because the other 99% of people
in here aren't gonna do it.
That's it, literally if I
wasn't contractually obligated,
I would leave right now.
(laughing)
Literally that's the
punch line my friends.
What my career picking
it back up on the recall,
so cool I'm building the
business and then YouTube comes
out, YouTube is like
100 days old, I see it.
I got geez, I think this is gonna be big.
And in February of 2006 before
YouTube was even one years
old, I started wine show on YouTube.
It was called Wine Library TV.
I sat in front of a camera,
I had four bottles of wine
and I drank them for 20 minutes.
It was the best gig I ever
had but something very
interesting happened, in
episode one and you can go
and see it on YouTube now,
episode one of Wine Library TV.
When I started Wine Library
TV, when I asked one of my
stock guys to run out the
best buy to buy camera to do
the episode I thought
I was on the verge of
starting QVC, my intent
was the camera would be on
and I would take some
wines we had in the store
and I would sell them, I'm
a salesman, I'm in business.
The light goes on and literally
it's funny I looked at this
the other day, I can see
it, you know yourself, I can
see where I realize oh crap,
this is gonna be on the
internet forever and if I
actually don't love this wine,
it's probably a bad idea
for me to say it's good.
And I remember thinking,
you know how your brain can
think while you're doing something else.
Literally as I'm doing the
episode I'm thinking about
this scenario where somebody
comes up to me in a function
like this and hands me a
glass of wine and says what do
you think and I'm like oh, it's crap.
And they go aha, you said it was awesome.
And then Dateline showed up
and like why'd you say that.
I was like uh, so.
(laughing)
Right there in episode one,
I started actually giving
my opinions, luckily the
first episode was this really
$200 wine and they were great
but something very weird
happened, I started
reviewing wine on my show
that we sold that I
had relationships with.
People that took me into
their home in Napa Valley
and I would tell you, the American public,
that this wine sucked,
that it was off balance,
that it didn't work and
it caused a real bru ha ha
in 2006 and seven in my industry.
But it taught me something
incredibly important.
Number one, first of
all, content sells just
as much as advertising, that
was extremely new for me
and probably anybody a decade ago.
I couldn't believe that
this was a show that I was
putting out for free that
was distributed for free,
that had no hook, nothing
but people would see
me talk about Valpolicella in the episode,
go to the website and buy
a different Valpolicella
or what have you, it
was super fascinating.
Number two, I just knew
that authenticity mattered
and that transparency was
coming a lot of what we
see with privacy now as
just an inevitable future
but then my career took it's biggest turn.
I wake up one morning and
Google buys YouTube for
1.7 billion dollars and
I read the article in the
Wall Street Journal and
it speaks about this
gentleman who made a ton
of money on a $25,000 angel
investment into Google, he
made like 10 million bucks.
And I said what is that
and so actually it's really
funny to tell you this story.
Literally yesterday I was
in the Wall Street Journal.
They have a section now, your
best and worse investment
and I told my best which is Facebook.
But Google sells and I
realize this talent I have of
understanding consumers
and what they're gonna do
email, eCommerce, Google
Ad Words, YouTube,
I don't need to use just
for selling more wine.
I need to figure out
how to do this bigger.
I'm an angel investor
now which I didn't really
understand what it meant but
I Googled it and I learned
and within the next 12
months, I made my first three
investments and that was
Twitter, Facebook and Tumbler
so couple things, I'm rich.
(laughing)
Two, I watched from coast
to coast something that
everybody believed was
small and didn't matter
to go and become the
thing that we most fear.
Literally I in the last
decade have lived a life
advocating for a platform
that went from this is not
a big deal, only my
kids use this in college
to literally it being on
the verge of having to be
regulated by the government
because it has too much power.
That's black and white
and so did all of you.
All of you from the day
you heard about Facebook
to today have watched it go
from some silly thing that
either you or your younger
siblings or your kids,
what, who cares, means nothing
to the CEOs testifying,
we're talking about the biggest.
If you think that that
platform and LinkedIn
and I'll go back to that
in a minute do not have the
ability to affect your business, you
are not thinking big enough,
you're thinking basic.
You're making the judgment
on the one guy or gal you
call on, you know what you're
doing, you're making the
judgment on a focus group of one.
You call on Stan at this retail
organization and Stan's 67
and he still has a piece
of shit flip phone, right?
What you don't realize is
that Stan makes decisions
in a million different
ways including the four
people that report to Stan
who happen to be 37 and 42
who live on these platforms
who have a ton of influence
on Stan's final decision
or a million other
things that can happen so
for me, the punchline is
very simple, we are living
through the greatest shift
of attention that the human
race has gone through since
the printing press, I'm a historian.
In my aforementioned report
card if you go to Instagram
after this talk and look at
it, you'll see F's everywhere,
D's everywhere, I got four
A's in my entire career,
all in gym and then you'll
notice a couple of B's
and they're all in history
and they're in history
because history always
tells me the future.
Everything I believe in
right now is based on my
learnings in education around
what happened in America
when we transitioned from
the radio the television.
The biggest companies,
the biggest wealth was
created in that transition
because our attention
shift from sitting in the
living room and listening to TV.
Boxing and horse racing and
baseball are number one in
America because that platform
of audio was great for it.
Football and basketball
emerge in the TV era.
Very basic, very easy to
understand, John F Kennedy
loses the debate on the
radio, wins it on television.
My friends, history will
tell you the future.
And let me promise you this
fact, if you leave with
anything in this talk, these
platforms are effecting
your business dramatically
more than you realize.
In the hidden, I don't
believe, 'cause I did a lot of
homework that you're losing
the business to somebody else
because they're effectively
out marketing you on Facebook
and LinkedIn, I believe that
you could be effectively
out marketing somebody and
you're leaving the Delta.
You know what's better than growing 18%?
Growing 50% and this is
leaving money and opportunity
on the table because you
haven't made the mental
and strategic decision, do
you know how many vendors
give me stuff for free or
offer it for free or highly
discount it, all day, all day
because I produce content.
Like my refrigeration, my,
we just built out a 50,000
square foot studio in Long Island City.
I've gotten so much
awareness now with my content
that people are not only
offering me the kitchen supplies
and the HVAC and the
painting and the wall,
not only are they offering it for free,
I've got companies offering to pay me to
give me the stuff for free.
It's just media, it's just attention.
They're not Mother Teresa,
they don't like me.
They like the attention they get from me
to who they're trying to reach.
If Gary's using this video company,
well then I should too,
this is very basic.
It's very hard to wrap your head around.
I come from an immigrant one store retail
New Jersey shop, I get it.
I spent all my time, I get
thousands of emails a week
from SMBs and mid market
businesses from zero to 50 million.
I understand a lot of what
I'm talking about is tough
to make the connection point
on but I am convinced that
nobody here is confused that
we are now living in this
culture, the literally,
literally the only thing
that's stopping you is
typing in words into YouTube
and Google to do the homework on how.
I know that people here
can make, let's talk about
being media verses being a salesperson.
I know people here can
talk about their product
and service as a whole, not
specifically their product.
How many people have been
business for 20 years or more
in what they do, raise
your hands, raise 'em.
The utter expertise that
is sitting in your head
of pattern recognition
and things to look out.
Do you understand that if you made,
how many people here are
a vendor trying to get to
somebody here and sell their
products, raise your hands.
Just curious, raise 'em
high please, amazing.
Do you understand that for
the majority in this room
that if you made what
is called a SlideShare.
It's a deck, it's owned by
LinkedIn and this is just on
the education of understanding
what's happening in our
world, that if you made a
slide of the value of what your
thing is, like, there's
not, I don't know every nook
and cranny but let me give you an example.
If you're a window supplier,
let's just go there.
That comes natural to me,
if you're a window supplier,
if you made a slide that
said the value for retail
operations to transition
or replace their windows
every seven years, if you
titled it that, the value,
the disproportionate, now
I'm doing a little copyright.
The Disproportionate ROI of
switching out your window
fixtures every seven years at retail.
If you make that Deck and in that deck,
you make 13, 14, 15 pictures,
written words, a deck,
a presentation that was
more as if you were a media
company or a b to b magazine,
not as a sales pitch,
it's just general information,
there is no your phone
number at the end and
if you buy now, nothing.
No right hook, just jabs, just content,
that if you made the
disproportionate ROI of changing out
your window fixtures at
retail every seven years deck
and you put that on
LinkedIn and you spent,
stick with me here, 1500 to
$2,000 targeting employees
of people that are in your
funnel, in your market,
people that you are trying to reach,
you would be flabbergasted
at the conversion
rate of those kind of
executions, I know this
because I invest a lot
in b to b sass businesses
and service providers and
have made a lot of money
in the exits and the going
publics of these companies
because of the disproportionate
nature of their marketing
that has been so much more
progressive but if you think I
think that that's what's
happening back home on a normal
day, that people are sitting
around and saying hey,
let's start a podcast or
hey, let's make a deck
on SlideShare and run ads on LinkedIn.
I'm aware that we're in a
sales driven relationship,
shake your hand driven business, I get it.
That's exactly why what
I'm talking about matters.
It's where the delta sits,
when everybody's doing the
same thing, there's only so
much value in that execution.
When your next competitor at the booth,
when you're at this event,
when you're doin' the golf
outing, when you're buying the
ad in the b and b magazine,
when you're selling direct mail,
when you have a sales team,
it's all the same stuff,
becomes disproportionately
commoditized over time
and as you know it becomes
a race to the bottom on the dollars.
So I think it's an incredible
time to become a practitioner.
Look, a lot of you have huge
opinions, a lot of headline
readers in this room about
how this marketing works,
a lot of people here have
opinions on how Facebook works
for your business yet
you've never run a single
Facebook ad in your life,
a lot of you have a ton of
opinions on how Facebook
works for your business,
yet you don't even have
a Facebook account.
So a lot of opinions that
lack the reality but I will
tell you this, the people
in this room who wrap their
head around what I'm talking
about and I'm gonna take
it down a notch, I'm gonna
take it down a notch to bring
value to this room, I believe
everybody in this room,
how many people here have a
business that's doing over
a million dollars a year, raise your hand.
Every person that just raised their hands
should hire somebody
for 40 to $50,000 a year
to produce content and
distribute it on LinkedIn
and Facebook for their
business for one year
just so see what it feels like.
Here's the scary part when I hear that,
if you hire blindly, like you
know what you're gonna do.
Oh yeah, maybe I should
hire my niece, she's 23.
If you do the cliche thing
of hiring a young person
who uses social media to
hook up, not to sell crap
and you know nothing about it,
you won't know how to judge
it, thus you become
vulnerable so before you hire
the person for 40 to
$60,000 a year to do this
and try it for one year because
if your business is doing
over a million a year and
it's 2018 and you live in our
society, you're smart
enough to realize that risk
is worth it because even
if you sell nothing,
it's good to check the box
to know it doesn't work.
It's an ROI positive
event, if it doesn't work,
it keeps you from debating
if there's any truth
in my conversation, you
yourself as the manager,
C Suite or owner have to
become educated in this.
And let me say another
thing, this is just life.
You have the benefit of being
in business and being an
event like this, please,
for your own self,
I just have something that
you need to wrap your head
around, this technology
thing, it's not going back.
You do understand that
this is this computer in my
pocket that I'm holding
up right now is more
powerful than the computer
that Ronald Reagan had
to run the free world,
you do understand that.
You also do understand
that this computer that's
more powerful than what
Ronald Reagan had to run the
free world is gonna look
like a pager in a decade.
How many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years
and I don't mean you're
gonna crush it and then
buy an island, I mean
you're just really old
and you need to retire, how
many people by show of hands,
retiring in the next 10 years, alright?
Let's first clap it up because that's the
most hands of ever seen,
this is oldest even ever.
(applause)
For the 95% of you that
did not raise your hand,
you will be a operator
in business in a decade
and if you don't know what
I'm talking about right now
with LinkedIn and Facebook,
you are in deep shit
when it comes to machine
learning, AR, Crypto, Block Chain.
There's a million things coming.
That is like you running
the Boston Marathon tomorrow
yet you've done nothing to prepare.
Please please, I know we're having fun.
It's lighthearted, we're
laughing, this is awesome.
I'm enjoying it, I don't even
wanna get to the Q and A.
I just wanna just keep doin'
my Chris Rock thing up here.
But please let's take a quick
step back and understand
how big the stakes are,
I spoke at the 2012 or 11
Taxi and Limo Convention, I
was an early investor in Uber.
I walked on stage I said listen to me.
Yes, I have a lot to
gain for Uber's success.
But I'm looking at human beings
and it's not fun to think
about what the ramifications of that is.
I've already made enough
money, I don't need to.
I called my dad's friends
in LA who owned black car
services, anybody ever
live in LA or live in LA?
A couple people so you may
know in the late 70s when
my family and friends
immigrated to the US,
we went to New York and LA
and all the Russian guys
originally drove cabs and they eventually
owned all the black car services.
I called when Uber
started gaining traction
in San Francisco, I called AKA
when they came and visited,
we had meat, I had talked
to my dad's friend Madig
and Nikkoli and Vladimir
and all these freakin'
cliche Russian names.
(laughing)
And I said to them, listen
to me, this is a problem.
And they looked at me and they laughed.
And here's why they laughed.
They came to this country with $4.
And over the course of
30 years, they pulled
themselves up from nothing to owning these
multi million dollar businesses
and they were 62 and 57
and like in that place
and they laughed at me
and they said I literally
can hear it in my ear.
Okay, okay, heavy Russian accent, you know
but English which was interesting because
they don't think I can
speak Russian well enough
which is very disrespectful,
nonetheless, they go okay,
one more time, you're saying
that they're gonna take
the phone, hit a button
and the limo's gonna.
And they literally laughed at me and eight
more liters of Vodka.
(laughing)
Here's where it doesn't get
funny 'cause it's real life.
36 months later those three
core gentlemen that I'm thinking
about businesses were
worth a dime on the dollar
that they were worth three years earlier.
Uber collapsed their
business, it wasn't pretty.
It was carnage, technology
is gonna eat everything.
I don't know your businesses
well enough to know
where that plays in but this is basic.
This is the biggest force in our society.
And we need to ride that
wave, not have it crush us.
Period, you have to figure
out how to make technology
your teammate, not your rival.
You can't fear monger it
and you can't put your head
in the sand, you're gonna
be hearing about robots that
are gonna kill us which is
gonna be true so good news.
We're fairly old, we'll probably miss it
but our kids are
finished, I'm not kidding.
And so please wrap your
head around how big this is.
And please start going to the
two biggest search engines
in the world, I don't
know how you learn either
Google and read how do I use
Facebook to sell HVAC units
to retail establishments, Enter.
Or you may learn like me
'cause I'm not good at reading.
Go to YouTube, the number two
search engine in the world.
How do I sell HVAC units to retail, Enter
and watch a video, listen
while you run, read.
I don't care how you consume content.
But if one of you, if one
of you heed my advice this
morning and get to action,
if 10 of you who were poo
pooing this whole thing
this morning when you got
your Starbucks are
listening to a business man,
not a futurist, not an
author, not a student,
somebody who makes
money, somebody who helps
other people make money, businessman.
If you hear me loud and clear,
if you do something about
it, we've accomplished
what I was hoping to this
morning, I wish you health
and I appreciate your time.
(applause)
- So we have a few minutes for questions.
We have two floor mics,
do we have any questions
from the floor, is someone
coming up to the mics?
Okay, great, Matthew.
- Good afternoon.
- Hey Brother, what's your
name?
- Matthew Haling.
- Hey Matt.
- How you doin'?
What's your feelings on
releasing duplication
of content at the same
time on multiple platforms
or spacing it out and moving
in different directions?
- I'm not worried about the
spacing out because somebody
might be on LinkedIn, somebody
might be on Instagram,
somebody might be on YouTube,
I'm worried about the context.
The same picture to the
same person acts differently
on Pinterest, Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter because
your psychology is different,
the average 47 year old
female in this room,
when she's on Pinterest,
she's in an aspiration to
buy, buying, window shopping.
When she's on Facebook, she's
keeping up with her world.
She's in a different mindset
so your content has to have
different words or different angles to it.
People distribute across
all of them for efficiency
because they think of it as direct mail
and things of that nature
but they're underestimating
the psychology of the person
when they're consuming it.
So you'll see on my Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram
similar stuff but you'll
notice that the copy that
associates with it is very
different and that's what
I have to do with it,
including when you're writing
something about hey, I put
out a lot of stuff of like
I just don't understand
why people hate their job.
Meaning we just spend way
too much time at work.
And I know you have to
put a roof over your head.
But my big thing is like
sell your house or live more
humbly and get a job that
pays less because being
miserable 63% of your time
is a bad strategy, period.
When I put out that
content on Sunday night
and Monday morning and Friday afternoon,
it does 30,000 times better
because that's when you're
in that mindset and so
a big one for b to b.
I love pounding the day after Labor Day.
Literally the Tuesday to
Friday after Labor Day
is some of the places
where I make the most money
because business people
feel the tension of being
checked out in August and
they feel like they have
to move quickly and make some decisions.
Psychology matters, my friend.
- Okay, awesome, thank you.
- Thanks Matthew.
- Hi, Troy Bachelor.
- Hey, Troy.
- [Troy] Troy right, how do
you see the transition of
voice in this space, like
Alexa, Google Home and all that
playing into the content marketing?
- So it's no question the
place that I'm most bullish.
I've stopped investing
for the last three years
because after making a
lot of money in investing
and as you guys know,
everybody now has a start up.
And just like I was tired
of meeting every person
who's got the I'm the Uber
of donuts, what the fuck
does that mean?
(laughing)
So but I'm gonna get
back into investing again
because all the apps that
are gonna be built on top of
Alexa are the next
Spotify, Instagram, Waze.
I think it's gonna change our lives.
I think you're gonna be
stunned how quickly you're
gonna have an Alexa or Google
Home or Apple Pod in your
bedroom, in your bathroom,
it's, you guys have to
understand, the reason there
are 60 year old men in here
texting right is because it's faster.
No matter how much we hate
technology or fear it,
speed is something we are addicted to.
Do you know why you
don't care about privacy?
'Cause you're willin'
to give it up for speed.
It's a tough thing for
humans to grapple with
but it's how we act,
it's faster for me to say
Alexa, what's my Tuesday
look like or order bananas
or help me get that vendor, I
think it's a huge huge deal.
But it's extremely early,
I think of it as like when
we were first discovering
land, you come over.
There's the people that see the berry bush
and they don't know if it's poison or not.
And the guys goes eat,
like oh shit and they die.
And the next one's like
oh delicious, raspberries.
That's what's gonna happen
on Alexa over the next three
to four years, there's a
lot of people that are gonna
spend time and money and
lose but then there's
gonna be people that buy all
of Manhattan for a dollar.
- [Troy] But the content
you see transitioning
over into the voice as well?
- I think humans have consumed
content in written word,
pictures, videos and audio
forever and that will continue
to change and there's ebbs and flows.
To me, before anybody thinks
about what their Alexa
strategy is, I would
say much like I elevated
and went from selling wine to
becoming America's wine guy
can you go from selling
whatever the hell you sell to
being the b to b leader of
thinking around the genre.
I think everybody here needs
a weekly or monthly podcast.
You have to understand, b to b's the best.
Your stinkin' podcast
can have 88 listeners
but that could have a five
million dollar impact.
So I think, I'm obsessed with voice.
I would argue everybody here
should be thinking about
producing a podcast first.
There's an app, I'm not an
investor but I push it a lot
so that's why people think I'm hedging.
It's called Anchor.FM,
Anchor.FM, literally you can
record your podcast on
your phone, hit one button
and then distribute it to,
it does everything for you.
You should look into it
if you're debating this.
- Thank you.
- You got it, sir.
- Okay.
- I'm sorry, go ahead.
- [Ivan] Good morning, I'm
Ivan Piper from the Piper
Companies and I wanna take
just a little bit of a
different twist, one thing
that happened this morning
that really blew me away is
I've been in my own business
for a long long time, after
that I've had a little bit of
a path like yours where I
became a speaker and trainer
as well.
- Understood.
- [Ivan] The first question
you asked is does anybody
here know me and I was blown
away by how many people
didn't have any idea who you were.
In my world, the way that
I stay on the top of things
in speaking and training is
by following people like you.
I'm gonna see you and Tony in
Fort Lauderdale next month.
So I stay on top of all
that and to me, I see such
a great importance in personal
and professional development.
So forget about all the
tech stuff at the moment.
- Understood, mindset.
- I wanna know if you
can just give us something
to take away that I
think would be incredible
on that how important
that really is to every
single person here.
- I appreciate it, my big
thing is that's a funny area
for me, right, I think personal
development and motivation
can get really blurry and huckstery.
At the same token, I genuinely
believe that optimism
and offense is the only option.
So for me, I think the one
thing that I would say to
everybody is I don't
understand the ROI of fear,
dwelling or complaining, right?
I just, I can't figure it out.
The only people listening to
your problems are other losers.
(laughing)
(applause)
I mean it, right now if you
think you're complaining
or it comes natural to you,
just think for 40 seconds
who the person who you
talk to the most about it.
It's your miserable mom, it's your sister.
It's always that so I highly
recommend, I'm a big believer
in the auditing your circle
and really thinking about
who you're spending time with.
I just wanna remind everybody
you find what you're looking
for, my friends, it's very easy
right now to find negativity.
The problem is it's equally
easy to find positivity.
Mainstream media is making
a lot of money selling fear
and negativity and I see time is up
and you can email me Gary@Vaynermedia
or DM me on Instagram
for the four of you, let me
just say one thing that I'm
completely fascinated by
and this is not political.
This is just life, I can't
stop thinking about how easy
it is for somebody that
wants to inflict harm to
get into a car and drive into people.
It's the easiest move of all time.
There is no stopping anybody
ever for getting into a car
and driving it into a crowded
area, it is unstoppable.
I just want everybody to
actually understand that.
I then think why the hell
does that not happen in every
major city every single day,
I'm a data guy even though I'm
not and I'm an actions guy
and so I just think, listen.
The math is on our side, this
is the greatest era of all
time, for everything that
you're complaining about right,
taxes, race, me too, all
sorts of stuff that we need to
address and I'm happy that
we're addressing it and we're
only addressing it
because of the internet.
I hope everybody understands that.
The only reason me too and
all the good stuff that's
happening in our society
is happening is 'cause
three old white guys don't
control the media anymore.
I just want everybody to
wrap their head around that.
Number two, the data's on our side.
You know what's worse
than like unemployment,
this and that, the black plague,
the black plague is worse.
Our grandparents and
our great grandparents,
do you understand the
things we complain about?
My Uber just missed me and is
going around the block again.
Or oh you son of a bitch,
I ordered almond milk, not
soy milk at Starbucks, I
don't know about you guys
but I live life listening, I travel a lot.
I listen, the stuff we complain
about or we think is bad
would literally make our
great great grandfather
slice our throats, it is time
that we put what's happening
right now in perspective,
this is the greatest era to
ever be alive because of
modern medicine and the macro
of where we live and my
thought on this is if you
listened to everything I
talked about for the last hour,
if you think that's bad, you
are on defense in your life
and if you think it's
phenomenal, you're on offense.
And you need to make a decision.
Because you're either
on offense or defense.
Do not trick yourself into
thinking you're in the middle.
- Awesome.
(applause)
- We'll do one last question
and then for the three
other individuals, you'll be able to.
- DM me on Instagram, GaryVee,
I'll answer 'em today.
- One last question and then we'll wrap.
- [Sarah] Hi, Sarah
Milton with Greater Image.
- How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Good.
- So my question is
if you're new into having
pages on Facebook and LinkedIn,
how do you build followers?
- Content, hashtags,
collaborations, and the best
part of all, spending money on ads.
It's so funny, people put
organic growth on a pedestal,
why, if the advertising's under priced,
why not take advantage of it?
So I'll go through it slowly one more time
'cause I want people to win.
Every time you post
something, at this point
I think everybody knows what a hashtag is.
If you add hashtags,
that's discoverability
on these platforms, Instagram
and Twitter use it more.
LinkedIn and Facebook use
it less but they still work.
Collaborations, inviting,
the reason, how many
people here listen to podcasts, great.
So if you notice, look very careful.
A lot of the biggest podcasts have guests.
Why, because they use the
guests star power to build
audience, the thing I'm probably
most proud of it I don't
have guests, I've built
just through the content.
But collaborations, bringing
people on to co author
or interview them, think about
what your audience wants.
It's empathy, empathy is
the secret to all of this.
If you actually care about the audience
instead of your own following
count and your business,
you'll get what you
actually want, make sense?
- Yes it does.
- But no question for
this industry, the ads,
the ads are under priced.
I don't know what else to tell you.
You could target individuals
you're looking for,
locations you're looking
for, again, all this hysteria
Cambridge Analytica is
'cause it works, it works.
So the ads and then again, it's Google.
How do I run LinkedIn
and that, it's all there.
The reason I don't talk,
I don't have a white board
or slides is that blocking and
tackling is free on Google.
The reason I spent my
time on the talk is you're
not gonna block and tackle
until you understand the
strategic and philosophical
reason this is happening
and what the white space
is, that is if you wanna
understand what I just
did, I gotta get you to
actually understand this is real for real,
for real, for real, no
hahaha, then, this guys
on his phone right now, he
literally can go to Google.
Type in, right.
(laughing)
Just so you know, I just watched you.
I'm pumped, I'm like he's hustling.
Forget what I'm doin'.
(laughing)
The information is on the internet.
It costs zero dollars and zero cents.
The thing that's stopping people
is fear, lack of education
and ideology, all three bad
ideas when it comes to business.
- Awesome, let's give it up to Gary Vee.
- Thank you.
(applause)
Thank you so much, thank
you, that's so nice.
(applause)
- Thanks Gary, great talk.
- Enjoyed it.
Thank you guys, that's
very nice, thank you.
- Right back there.
(upbeat music)